let's hold hands if you're scared I
wanna beat your ass on a sandwich girl
isn't this amazing
oh yes huh yeah we can touch each ad
there jack
well our wrinkly my hands are it's
really freaky it okay
oh great it's like that a yes oh my god
click click the number one button on
your controller uh what does I do inside
ones you have lazy fingers ok can we
join each other like I had introduced
these light sabers which bun oh my god
we can have a sword battle let's do this
which theater are you in one two I came
from three um let's see here
I'll join you then uh uh fight me dinner
what did you do to me I don't know what
is your hand doing you fighting with
your hand behind your back like a French
all right on god I wasn't doing that
we're totally doing that oh my god this
is like Star Wars Episode one certainly
I'll burn you while you're starting
Christian Oh God
twist your nipples
oh god what just happened where did you
go you where are you
you killed me oh I can't kill you
that's cool pew pew pew pew this Chinese
even we could play cowboys ha ha Oh your
hand is going through your junk it looks
really weird
really yes especially since we make that
face and I and I'm trying to grab your
oh oh
grab my gunk I'm grabbing your nips this
up this is the most immersive immersive
experience of my life
we have to go into the hallway like
gentlemen - I am a gentleman
arguing gentlemen ha ha all right fight
me let's fight you had as a child you
just out swinging 316 oh now you got me
- gadget I have a laser
I was laser pointed light saber show up
on you I thought there's gonna be like a
snipers aim hey we should just I'm gonna
be jealous
we run at each other okay and hit just
like our horses okay okay
three two one charge oh my god anyone I
window you I went spit over oh my god
the light is happening the leg is real
all right peace peace peace peace ah
don't hurt me okay let's go and light
weighted and light say we're off we need
to enter the cinema right yep can I can
i grab your ass don't do it do it great
we haven't even started Jack God oh so
good how do you sit down stop stop I'm
trying to sit down stop there's such a
pair of stop it
how do I turn I swear to God I could sit
down there we go
ah there we go oh hi hi hi best game
ever I'm outta here
okay yes oh god my hand my hand what is
going a hundred I thought the game would
break and I could just like put might in
the whole way out to you I'm twisting up
my hand so much it's becoming a snake oh
yeah oh yeah are you doing over there
that's my chest okay let's do rock paper
scissor okay well we can only do rock
paper Mikaela sister rock paper okay sir
one go rock paper scissor okay we're
both rock okay you look like the [ __ ]
and everything I know right
hey paper says oh man you won I wash
wait everybody wait if I hold my control
of my fingers that it it's my own saber
consider on a saber yeah Thank You saber
Oh Marian as good as we just look like
you're doing that but whatever let's go
in and the theater to see what's going
on here horse sink free viewing I don't
oh god I've set default video alright so
let's play a video I'll play one ah hi
hi hi Marc
hi I got a touch his face now we can put
mark in the title of the video and
everyone's cake on him yeah we could put
them in the tags and in our descriptions
cinema with Micah play No uh wait I want
to change me yeah he's as big as his
voice sounds changes to close your mouth
okay which do we have a song request
from from the audience what did the
audience think okay I have a song okay
do it a little uh karaoke food is your
guy doing Connie okay okay
touch your nose come here don't you oh
don't do that I'm scratching your nose
come here yeah hop it you have a tickle
you have another booger hey get it so
this family pit good throw many people
out there I want to touch puta paws ass
oh yeah oh my god
sit next to me Jackie okay you're an
inspiration not only to me oh hello if
you hold let's hold hands if you're
scared this is the good thing okay wait
wait wait wait can I get care
can I get gear can you hold the armor on
yes oh it started again ah
kill it kill it again flat oh thank god
thank you I could pause it
you have to open curtain stare back that
is again that's really short of like
before okay tell me much uh what's crops
oh there's a cheer oh there's two Cheers
it's the town and I have a talk oh my
god what are you doing
oh my god there's there's three man X oh
dude what is going on r2d2 oh my god
what uh you're inside inside what did
you do I'm sorry Alice there you go
talk shows oh wow what did you wait a
terrific audience
hey welcome to Jack candy campaigners
today we're gonna talk about lady V
sneaker all right join me now okay join
me I'm joined whoa whoa oh there we go
coming you in the toilet
yeah so glad you made sure good to see
ya
you're like happy last night hi
oh my god your happens what is wrong
with tag Jean away from me you're ready
to go okay alright going well it's
finally seeing a karaoke dotson oh there
we go
oh my god let's see it play yes better
then get oh my god I'm pretty it's
playing for me so don't ruin this for me
okay I just sit here silently watch look
more amazed please because the music is
what this amazing whoo the show sergeant
it's literally just a cube for the show
- sighs oh Jesus Christ
dance music yeah it's too loud whatever
what is your like I walk over You Dende
can't get it oh this is a minute I know
I'll have to do this in two more minutes
yeah cause it's like abnormally loud for
us my ears are exploding you spin in a
circle fight me fight me in real life
blow it to even lift bro oh you killed
me next row the way you do bro Oh bro
whoa whoa I'm flying
oh my god whoo do it again
dude [ __ ] wah-wah there's not a flower
i life we are nibble aside oh oh my god
I have to turn the volume down all of it
this is too much for me sir oh my god
what uh what did you know three minutes
of madness again no I'm not doing that
so why did markiplier say [ __ ] like that
isn't why I don't understand yes saying
for me Jack the copper eye oh yes I'll
sing to my lightsabers [ __ ] it's too
much we'll do one verse each okay all
right one iron that's you settle down
and yeah I don't know this song will
read the lyrics Jack go and your merry
nah-ah-ah heard that you dreams came
true bet you did gave you things I
didn't give to you oh why you so shy
ain't like you to hold back or hide from
light I don't think that was right catch
me Dad catch me I never let go
whose hands are who I don't know um I
have to end it here bro yeah I have to
go soon anyway go fist let's see a ste
yep Oprah's good you gotta like run from
either end of the hall
oh don't laser going breath me Oh